- May 26th is Red Nose Day on NBC.
It's a great cause that's helped out
millions of kids over the years.
And here to tell us more
about it is none other than
People Magazine's reigning
sexiest man alive, Paul Rudd.
(exciting music)
I love it, nice to see you Paul.
So where are you calling from?
- Nice to see you, Kelly.
- [Kelly] Where are you calling from?
- New York.
- [Kelly] Oh, okay.
- Calling from New York.
- Right on.
Tell us more about Red Nose Day, Paul.
- Well, Red Nose Day is
this amazing organization
that was started in
2015 by Richard Curtis,
who is a great writer and
director that many people know.
But it supports all kinds
of kids all over the world
with lots of programs,
makes sure that they're safe
and they're healthy and
educated and empowered.
And since then, they've
helped over 30 million kids.
They've raised 275 million dollars
from people everywhere
donating to this, incredible.
- Yeah, I've worked with them for years.
It's the coolest, coolest organization.
It actually makes a huge impact.
How did you get involved?
- I was invited years ago by Richard
and I was really, you know,
one, they put together these
shows and they're really funny.
And I got to do a fun sketch
where I played Danny Hall,
the male version of Annie Hall.
And it was a lot of fun and it was funny
and it was all part of this show.
And with every year, I started getting
more and more involved
because I was just so impressed
with what Red Nose Day was all about.
And I got to go to Maine
and this was where things really became,
(phone dings)
that's my, I got an email.
- Hey, you got an email, Paul.
- This is where things got
really, you know, major for me
because I got to go to Maine
and really see firsthand
what kind of impact these
donations were making.
You know, so many times,
we give our money to different charities
and it's an incredible thing
but we don't really get to
see, up close and personal,
the difference that they're
making, our donations.
And I got to go to
Maine and go to a school
and meet a lot of kids that were,
you know, they were food insecure.
They needed to be, they needed help.
And all of these kids were being fed
and food was provided
through Red Nose Day.
I met all of these amazing workers there,
people in the school,
and it had such a profound impact on me
that I just wanted to stay
involved in whatever way I could.
- You're absolutely right, man.
It's a different thing.
Like, you know, we give money to things
and sometimes you don't know where it goes
and I've been involved in that since too.
That's why I love Red Nose Day,
because I've actually seen,
how you saw the direct impact in Maine,
you see the direct impact.
Like not only on the kids that it impacts,
but their families, it's
the domino effect of it.
And it's a really, really
beautiful thing to be a part of.
It's a great cause.
Thank you so much for giving us a call
and I love your wallpaper.
- Thanks so much.
- [Kelly] I dig it.
- Get your (indistinct).
- Oh yeah, I feel left out.
I love it, bye Paul,
talk to you next time.